that's not the plan
my friend blueface
is on house arrest
we saw a couple weeks ago you got picked
up
made bail rather quickly
we're supposed to do this in LA and
you're like man come hey come to Vegas I
can't leave it yeah we have plans the
day I got arrested we were supposed to
do this yeah I thought I was gonna make
it out of court blue face it's uh good
to see you uh not incarcerated thank you
brother you do have the uh the bracelet
on your ankle currently
um and we are in Las Vegas and we have
the first artist on milk music MILF
music your baby mama
she is here
Jaden
yeah uh she just dropped her new song
Stewie yeah like two days ago what you
do you think she's the right story
I think she looks like drewski really
did you see that okay listen I thought I
saw that you've decided yeah I think
it's funny but do you look like do you
see like do you see what everyone else
sees like I could be his little sister
maybe
I mean maybe I don't know
um no but I get the Stewie thing see I
like the self-deprecation that's all I'm
a white guy so all we do is
self-deprecate so I like the fact okay
because I have a giant head all my
friends make fun of me because you do
gotta be there actually when we go to
that like look at this there's a reason
why I wear a hat like I'm dumbed up Bros
in harmony bro
um but uh yeah the Stewie thing is I
think it's funny I think I mean [__] I
don't I don't give a [__] yeah I mean
why not so when you like because listen
obviously you have been
you have been on in some sort of
Spotlight due to your you know
relationship with blue over the last you
know three or four years right yeah
we've seen a lot of drama a lot of
craziness you put your paws on people
um
I feel like I just just went on a
YouTube diving so I don't know it could
be wrong I could yeah I might have I
might have um but I'm curious let's just
get back to the beginning how did you
guys initially meet up because you were
like baby mama Uno right right so you're
the first one
you're the OG the OT
um how did you guys do that let's take
it back how did you guys first meet uh
we went to high school together okay in
high school
and uh was this one he was playing
football yeah a little football star or
whatever so you're the football star and
then you got like do you guys go to prom
together yeah yeah we went to yours yeah
oh so you guys did go to prom yeah oh
nice how was prom did you guys have sex
in prom
after yeah I don't know you know not
that prom yeah in and out
High uh and so
give me kind of because for you like
um
there's been so much
controversy regarding Blues
relationships in general yeah period
um I feel like you've you know you had
to have dealt with a lot of
difficult situations to pay to pay
attention to online or not pay attention
to like do you learn a lot of the
comments or a lot of the
stuff people say about you maybe your
relationship because obviously you have
a kid like right yeah
um I don't let it bother me I mean I
think because like I know what it is in
real life it's kind of like the internet
just they see one little 25 and they
make it into like 110 so I don't I don't
let what they say bother me
um blue for you is this MILF music thing
a real thing
I think I think we'll get more talent
coming in based off her
impression you know so in order to be on
your new label you have to have child
yeah you gotta have a kid like what's
the objects we're auditioning Baby Daddy
has to be a reference like he asked
about you so it doesn't have to be your
baby Mama's only on MILF music it could
be anybody who's got children yeah yeah
definitely can you be pregnant yeah yeah
what if someone's just expecting are you
pregnant you could be okay so that
qualifies
so all we got to know is you got you got
something to lose you know you got
something to live for you got something
to die for you're not just like taking
advantage of the situation